hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast parathyroid functional states
how to define and how to assess I am
Brenda Kelly Kim of labyrinth and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's webcast is presented by lab
routes comm the leading social media
site for science professionals and
sponsored by dire sauron daya Soren is
an Italian multinational group and a
global leader in the market for in vitro
diagnostics for over 40 years the group
has been developing producing and
commercializing dies not Gnostic tests
for a wide range of clinical areas
dinosaur tests are designed for hospital
and private testing laboratories and the
markets of immuno diagnostics and
molecular diagnostics before we start
there are a few instructions we want to
know how you we want to hear from you
during this interactive broadcast so
please ask questions or leave us a
comment answers are always welcome to
you can do this by hitting the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window and typing in your
comments and questions we'll try to get
to as many of your questions as we can
today want a better look you can enlarge
the slide window by clicking on the
screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you can't
hear or see this presentation properly
please let us know by clicking on the
support button or use the Q&A button
lower left to let us know we'll try to
make sure we resolve any issues now
let's get right to today's presenter we
are proud to welcome dr. Souter program
dr. Rao section head bone and mineral
mineral metabolism and director of bone
and mineral research laboratory Henry
Ford Hospital in Detroit Michigan a
position he has held continuously since
1995 it is the best bone
histomorphometry lab in the state and
one of the best in the country under his
direction the lab has seen has been
conducting both basic and clinical
research and published extensively on
the pathogenesis of bone fragility
age-related bone loss
mechanism of a typical fractures in the
role of vitamin D parathyroid adenoma
size and disease expression and on
parathyroid tumor Genesis dr. Rao has
more than 100 peer-reviewed papers 100
symposium proceedings abstracts and
letters to the editor and ten book
chapters is a founding member of the
Indian society of bone and mineral
research which he helped launch in 1997
dr. Rao has received a number of awards
including the Willard Oh Thompson
traveling scholar award in the American
College of Physicians in 1986 and the
frame award from the american society of
bone and mineral research in 1999 he is
a fellow of the American College of
Physicians and the American Association
of clinical and endocrinologists am I'll
turn it over to dr. Rao for his
presentation good afternoon and good
morning for some of you who may not be
in the same time zone my name is dr.
sahakara um I am the head of the bundle
division here in Section Head of formal
metabolism today I will be presenting on
palla fired functional states how to
define and how to assess these are my
financial discusses our grant support
from NIH I am on the speaker's bureau of
the lily company I have a financial
relationship to the isola I serve on the
advisory board for the DEA soaring
receiving an honorarium from da Soren to
provide this presentation I will not
discuss off-label or investigational use
in this presentation the objectives are
threefold first to discuss the
physiologic and measurement
considerations role of pth in normal
human physiology measuring and you took
it in serum pth levels the second part
and present analysis in the alternate
path our function be genetic sporadic
acquired or indeterminate or unknown in
which PT HSS become very important in
in which type of power fire dysfunction
the clinician is dealing with and
finally if time permits I present some
clinical examples to highlight the above
four different categories I will not be
discussing managing statistics since
there are clinicians and nominations and
I'll entertain questions at the end the
role of parathyroid hormone in normal
human physiology is well known for just
to review briefly para fired is a small
gland located right behind the thyroid
gland which secretes parathyroid hormone
and has a PTH receptor and it works on
three important organs the bone the
kidney and inter sign in the kidney it
increases the renal tubular reabsorption
of phosphate and on the bone it
increases the bonus option and an
interesting it increases the calcium
absorption and because of this tight
regulation serum calcium actually is
maintained within a very narrow range
although within an individual it is much
narrower than the normal referencing
that is normally given for example with
individual the calcium ray range is only
by about half a milligram where is
between individuals it can range up to
two milligrams the next slide
illustrates that the narrow range under
which it functions for example most
individuals will be in this small radio
so the serum calcium varies very little
in the normal physiology as the serum
calcium Falls the PTH Rises of the serum
calcium rises the pth false and this
narrow range is maintained constantly
with interaction of calcitonin
parathyroid hormone on 125 dihydroxy
vitamin D the next slide shows the
well-known actions the parathyroid
hormone the most important one of the
oldest one that we know is increasing
renal tubular phosphate excretion by
inhibiting tubular reabsorption of
phosphate it increases reloadable
reproduction of calcium therefore the
serum calcium is high in most
individuals at the same time the urine
calcium is relatively low it increases
the bone resorption by activating the
osteoclast action n number but also
increases the osteoblast number and its
lifespan it
the industrial calcium absorption these
are the key elements in maintaining the
calcium homeostasis although the
well-established and most studied organs
are kidney and bone and indirectly
intestinal tract there is some evidence
to suggest that power hormone has
actions on the vascular smooth muscle
hypertension cardiac myocyte brain in
terms of the psychic overtones whether
it is related to high calcium or high
pts is still being debated PTH
measurements has a long history and
evolution the earliest measurement was
mainly measuring the FASTA chu'lak
actions commonly known as tubular
reabsorption of phosphate or tea and pgr
for the next generation of parathyroid
hormone function study was mainly based
on the naproxen a cyclic A&P like any
other polypeptide hormones this will
increase the cyclic EMP and finally in
the early late 60s and early 70s we got
into the c-terminal asses primarily
using the chicken or guinea pig for
developing the antibodies unfortunately
c-terminal essays were not as effective
as distributary as the current asses it
was later replaced by the big molecule
ras and i will show you the figure what
they differ in terms of the epitopes
then the most recent one of the intact
parathyroid hormone asses they went
through three generations of first
generation second generation now the
third generation PTH is a straight
peptide 1 2 84 molecule the initial
carboxy-terminal assays were mainly
focused on this region of the molecule
and those are called the c-terminal
asses in the next generation we had the
mid molecules mainly looking at the mid
molecule of the PTH and finally the
intact hormones used both the
amino-terminal c-terminal as a captured
antibodies so that they were having a
good antibody detection of the intact
molecule on little corner here you will
see that the 12 84 compounds in the
third generation have a ninety-two
percent probability of detecting the
intact hormone whereas carboxy-terminal
at only 78
sent of the probability of detecting the
parathyroid hormone so the new addresses
are much better I'll give you some
examples of problems with the different
gases currently there is it recent acid
that has been developed because of the
different species of molecules that
circulate the most one that interferes
with most of the commercially available
intact essence is the 7284 fragment but
the newer and most sensitive what I call
it probably is the highly sensitive
intact pth sa that is developed by dear
Sauron zero reactivity to the 7280 for
fragments and probably this is prob will
prove to be the best in the clinical
practice interpretation of the PTH
results depends on the role of life and
indeed nutritional status because pts 25
lakhs vitamin do you have different
relationship some have recommended that
the vitamin D status be adjusted to the
PTH reference range however many
challenges exist to this approach very
few if any pts reference range are based
on the prevailing vitamin D nutritional
status and 25 watts vitamin D
relationship is nonlinear as are many
perhaps almost all biologic relationship
controversy about the optimal level of
25-hydroxyvitamin D and then finally how
do we account for the class of nutrition
therefore at the present time the PT HS
is a reference range are based on the
so-called healthy individuals without
any reference to 25 Roxy vitamin D in
the next few slides I will illustrate
relationship between PT HSA and 25 c
vitamin D one of the oldest one is comes
from dr. gloss where he looked at this
125 Roxy vitamin B on the x-axis and pth
on the y-axis showing that it is a
curvilinear relationship around 25 to 30
nanograms the PTA starts to rise but
it's not a linear relationship as you
can see there are many with very high
pth levels there are also many with a
low pth levels even though vitamin D is
present the next slide shows a larger
group of people again looking at the inn
p th and 25 rocks vitamin D again
showing that around 30 nanograms per ml
pts starts plateau and this was in
nineteen in early 2000 published from a
data available from a clinical trial on
the other hand with collaboration with
the DEA Sauron and lab call we analyzed
close to 300,000 samples looking at the
PTH 25 dogs a vitamin D relationship I
know it's a crowded slide what it shows
is that at the age level for really
given age patients with higher age have
a higher pts compared to the lower age
group and the number of people with
higher pth at the older age group is
much higher than the lower age group so
it it turns out that the PTH sa depends
on the 25-hydroxyvitamin D level and
also on the age level I also looked at
although I have not published it i
thought i will share this one looked at
the seven different PTH asses in terms
of the ability to detect and it turns
out the ROC analysis suggests that all
seven performed reasonably well with a
rock value of 0 point A to point
ninety-two although we need more
specificity without losing the
sensitivity so the more insensitive
intact asses will be helpful for the
clinicians in making diagnosis
releasably looked at cross reactivity
and problems in collections in two
essays when we looked at the serum serum
there was a bias of 25 micrograms when
we looked at the plasma vs serum there
was a bias of 12 picograms when we
looked at two different essays CNM serum
there was a 8 picogram so the more
sensitive the assay the less bias will
be but usually in multiplicative the
same sample we get about 1.4 people
grant ml but between the individuals
it's quite wide
now I'll turn to the altar terrified
functional status we in the ideal
situation the parathyroid hormone sa
must conform to the physiology it must
be able to separate from normal from
pathologic States must be undetectable
in non PTH mediator hypocalcemic state
such as cancer PT hrp producing
conditions granulomatous diseases it
must be elevated in almost all patients
with PTH mediator hypercalcemia and all
types of PHP t must be undetectable in
my high profile for extremes however
this ideal PT HSA is yet to be invented
since many patients with hyperthyroidism
will either have a an elevated PTH value
or non suppress PTH value some
interesting features about the
parathyroid gland it is a smallest of
all in decline glands it's only
milligram size but it aamir two-fold
increase in its size causes significant
clinical manifestations the normal
weight is about 40 to 60 milligrams most
individuals have four glands but can
range from 1 to 12 grams in number can
mitigate can migrate along the midline
down to the pubic ranges abnormal glance
could be an enormous hyperplasia cell
carcinomas a five percent of singularity
nomas five percent or double at normas
ten percent of head plastic less than
one or cancer weight varies from 100
milligrams in an idea or two almost 45
grams which is probably the world record
so far as I know primary
hyperparathyroidism is the most common
cause of hypercalcemia as I mentioned
earlier it has either clearly elevated
pth levels or non suppressed meteors so
inappropriately normal value a better
way of expressing will be non suppress
PTH is superbly Monica Calif our hormone
level and in many patients the PTH level
usually about 20 picograms per it out in
cancer patients it is suppressed and in
other granulomatous conditions it may
not be it may be suppressed in most of
the time
it is a communist cause of hypercalcemia
in outpatients it is the second most
cause of all hypercalcemia it is a third
most common cause of endocrine disorder
estimated incidence is one to 200
depending on which survey years and it
can vary up to 11 thousand incidence
Rises with age usual ages 62 years more
common in women to the pre one ratio
more common after menopause perhaps
related to the estrogen deficiency there
does not appear to be any specific
racial predilection key feature saw that
hypercalcemia is almost always elevated
that's how the clinicians detect the
high becomes this condition pth is of
the normal or non suppressed
25-hydroxyvitamin d levels are variable
alkaloid phosphates levels are also
variable depending upon which part of
the country on which part of the world
the disease is diagnosed bone mineral
density is frequently low clinical
symptoms mostly asymptomatic but can be
symptomatic there are some genetic
variants of the Palo fire disease it's
mostly sporadic where if you are
familiar there are multiple endocrine
neoplasia types and one condition called
familial hypocalcemic hypercalcemia is
usually does not respond to power prior
surgery and the PTH essays are usually
within the reference range occasionally
they are elevated perhaps the new
Erastus will be better able to
distinguish this condition from the
usual sporadic parathyroid adenoma
originally there was a tenfold rise in
the parathyroid disease detection after
full or albeit suggested that calcium
testing in all stone patients there is a
four-fold rise after the biochemical
data are introduced by chemical
screening was introduced in the early
70s in this country although it is being
stable from 80's 90's there is some
suggestion that the incidents might be
decreasing in the mayo clinic series
however such decline in the incidence
has not been found in the Henry Ford
Hospital experience or in other centres
in an earlier era the disease was
euphemistic
referred to as a disease of stones moans
groans and with psychic overtones but
over the past quarter century it has
changed from a disease with symptoms to
a disease in search of symptoms
therefore the guidelines for
asymptomatic hyper-partisan how to
manage them who get surgery is developed
the traditional manifestations have been
replaced by quality of life issues bmd
and fractures some issues about the
cardiovascular disease diabetes in this
lip edenia and the question of
malignancy has been raised so the
traditional manifestations are still
seen in parts of the world where vitamin
D and calcium nutritional deficiencies
are endemic in addition to that the
growth of the parathyroid adenoma has
also declined for example in 1940s the
average size of the gland was about six
and a half grams whereas in the most
recent series from the Henry Ford system
is about 500 to 700 milligrams which is
much lower than it were to it was a
precipitous drop in the adenoma size
occurred in 1940s when the vitamin D was
added to the milk in contrast even in
the current situations the disease
presents much younger in the parts of
the world where vitamin D deficiency and
calcium deficiency is common whereas it
presents in the usual situation here
with only one and a half or two times
celebration of the parathyroid hormone
in contrast in other parts of the
country there is a 10 to 15 fold
increase in the power of our hormone we
also looked at the 25 rocks vitamin D
and the adenoma size and we found that
the lower the vitamin D level the larger
the gland size the higher the PTH level
as one would expect and similarly we
have looked at in the larger population
of close to 1,000 patients fully
surgically verified again the lower the
vitamin D level larger the gland size
depending upon size and when we looked
at the bigger glands versus smaller
glance the relationship continues to
exist regardless of the gland size it
appears that the growth of the tumor
is genetically determined whereas the
size of the tumor is determined by the
vitamin D status the newer to summarize
primary hyperparathyroidism calcium is
always abnormal PTH level may or may not
be elevated in our series it's about
two-thirds will have non suppressed PTH
about one-third will have increased pth
levels urine calcium is variable outline
Fosters is variable bone density is
almost always low many patients and is
symptomatic and it is usually detected
during routine by chemical screening
primary hyperparathyroidism both the
type one disease has seen in the East
Side east of the world and type 2
disease as seen in the West are
differentiated by the presence or
absence of the bone disease the new
entity that has come up because of the
frequent measurement of the PTH sa in
osteoporosis management is so-called
normal calcium in hydropower thyroidism
this clinical entity is somewhat
undefined yet but they almost always
have normal serum calcium but one must
exclude all known causes of elevated pts
such as low vitamin D level low urine
calcium patients who have other drugs
that will cause PTH elevation so once
you once excludes then one is diagnosed
with normal calcium in hypothyroidism
but it is unclear exactly what one
should do with these patients now I will
switch to the secondary and tertiary
hyperparameters chases have become even
more important the secondary
hyperparathyroidism normal or low serum
calcium it's almost always elevated
reaching it frequently low 25 watts
vitamin D and then all other features
that I have listed on this slide it's
usually associated the renal failure and
all vitamin D depletion or both but in
the West it is mostly renal failure
perhaps in the East Pakistan part of the
world which perhaps vitamin D deficiency
in this situation there is a decrease in
the 125 hydroxy vitamin D
which is important for maintenance of
serum calcium and there's also retention
of phosphate due to renal failure both
of which stimulate parathyroid hormone
causing continuous increase in the PTH
secretion as the renal failure occurs as
shown in the early slides as back as
1988 as the creatinine clearance
declines the production of 125 declines
and the rise in the PTH occurs and it is
due to the this events there's a
disturbance in the blood bone
equilibrium there is a decrease in the
calcium absorption and is it set point
of humanity in the parathyroid hormone
secretion that leads to the development
of parathyroid growth in little
hyperparathyroidism compared to primary
hyperparathyroidism it could be a
diffuse hyperplasia in the early stages
which can put prolonged stimulation of
parathyroid gland leads to the nodular
hyperplasia in which pth levels are much
higher and then sometimes it can be
associated with an adenoma within the
hyperplastic gland this is a slide their
first study that we'd number of years
ago in patients with renal
osteodystrophy with skeletal disease
present on the skeleton versus those who
don't have the skeletal manifestations
the pth levels are about twice as many
in patients with bone disease compared
to those who do not have the parathyroid
do not have the bone disease I will
switch to the next slide set which is an
important one give me one minute please
we also looked at the relationship
between the pth levels and the bone
disease in dialysis patient and pth here
serves a useful clinical purpose for
many clinicians as long as the PTH is
level or below 500 bowl disease is less
common whereas it's much more common
above the 500 micrograms per ml in
contrast to primary hyperparathyroidism
in patients renal osteodystrophy several
species of the carboxy-terminal or
n-terminal truncated PTH molecules
circulate therefore interference with
these molecules and separation of these
molecules in the newer essays might very
useful so the highly sensitive intact 12
84 sa then is developed by the DA
soaring with very very little with no
cross-reactivity in 1784 might be very
useful in patients or on dialysis as a
monitoring strategy PTH measurements are
required or recommended in patients in
stage 3 4 and 5 kidney disease depending
upon the severity of the
hyperparathyroidism they are measured
every 6 to 12 months or three to six
months tertiary hyperparathyroidism in
my definition and it is often misused
must have always hypercalcemia and
usually preceded by long-term secondary
hyperparathyroidism pth levels are
almost always high more than thousand
paper grams and these patients almost
always require surgical intervention let
me switch into the hypoparathyroidism
them the key feature saw they are always
hypocalcemic they have either very low
or very high PTH level depending upon if
they are due to deficiency of PTH
hormone or due to the resistance of the
PTH action on the target organs lower
undetectable is idiopathic or post
surgical heibel levels of seen in
pseudohypoparathyroidism again the PTH
asses are very helpful in diagnosing
patients with idiopathic hypothesis that
chikara leave now that the PTH is
available for treatment in sensitive
assay that is undetectable in such
situations we would be very helpful
other collaborative library data are
listed on this slide which are self
exponentially the hypoparathyroidism ado
the deficiency is an absolute or
relative the resistance is due to
genetic or acquired and there are few
circumstances where there is ineffective
hormone action due either to magnesium
deficiency chronic renal failure or
vitamin D
see the symptoms are well known of the
hypercalcemia but i would like to
concentrate on the complications since
many of these complications develop in
seriously and two of the first two
complication on the right hand right
side are irreversible therefore early
recognition is important whether the
newer PTH treatment for hyperthyroidism
will reduce the interplanar and
calcification is yet to be determined
one could use p th ese to distinguish
between PTS related hypocalcemia or
vitamin d related hypocalcemia depending
upon whether they have associated
symptoms for example cataract is more
common in the PTH but not in vitamin d
skin disease is more commonly quickly
it's related to the hypocalcemia and
then in vitamin d related soft tissue
calcifications are more frequent in pts
related than in vitamin be delighted one
could also use the PTH as characteristic
feature if it is lower high it is due to
the PTH related infant environmentally
literate almost always high and finally
normal levels of PGH are due to calcium
sensing receptor mutations magnesium
deficiency or ineffective whereas it is
always high in chronic renal failure
vitamin D depletion or
pseudohypoparathyroidism PTH assays are
also helpful in distinguishing clinical
clinicians whether it is due to
hypothyroidism or do too hungry bone
syndrome soon after surgery for a
patient with primary hyperparathyroidism
or for thyroid surgery traditionally be
dependent on the phosphate levels but
with the newer essays and faster SI time
it is possible to determine whether the
hypocalcemia is due to
hypoparathyroidism in which case it will
be low on and detectable or is it due to
hungry bone syndrome in which case it
was it'll be quite high this is a case
of pseudohypoparathyroidism so showing
the short stature and short metacarpals
a patient with the PTH resistance this
is a case of intro clinic as
gation a patient Coast operative
hypoparathyroidism showing bilateral
basal ganglia and calcification and also
cerebellar calcification as you can see
here and patient can develop a taxi
adieu to this unfortunately the current
bth treatment available may not reverse
this but early treatment might prevent
this until then we will not know whether
the PTH treatment will prevent
entertainer calcification in conclusion
I reviewed with you physiologic and
measurement considerations I discussed
the PTH measurements and vitamin d
effects on PTH measurements discuss
various types of previous measurements
and possibility of newly high sensitive
one 284 intact pth sa might very useful
because of its low cross reactivity 27
284 molecule circulating we discussed
the phenotypes of altered parathyroid
states such as primary secondary
tertiary normal calcining and various
types of hypothyroidism and I hope my
presentation has been very helpful and
informative since there is some time I
will spend trying to give you some
examples of cases there is a case of
severe hyperparathyroidism hardly one
can see the bone out critters before
powerful ectomy and six months after
parathyroidectomy the bone is
reconstituted but the deformities remain
permanent here's an example of osteitis
fibrosa cystica are brown tumor before
such a radiologic picture and one can
see that the calcium extruding from the
knee here from the drone tumor another
example of cortical thinning and with
fractures and the villagers is fine
showing on the right side and the full
of fourth bone marrow fibrosis that
occurs in primary hyperparathyroidism
somewhat similar to that occurs in renal
failure and this bone marrow fibrosis is
an important determinant of the ipoh
resistance in dialysis patients the more
pth the more [ __ ] marrow fibrosis
and more resistance to ipoh is a visible
parathyroid adenoma and a stunted lady
from eastern part of the world
sometimes you can get soft tissue
calcifications that can be seen in
patient but in Leicester dystrophy and
x-rays will show full calcifications and
this may be due to excess power of our
hormone phosphate calcium product that
is causing the deposition sometimes you
can see a clubbing of the fingers due to
superior solution and loss of the
terminal digits and one can hardly see
the terminal digits in the x-ray of this
particular patient that I showed you
earlier one can also see severe this
option of the symphysis pubis due to
very high pth levels and that can
progress and sometimes they can develop
protrusive aside heavily and deformities
that cannot be reversed due to severe
hyperpower piracy one can also see a
severe austerities fabulous cystica in
the symphysis pubis in the greater
trochanter here that can cause
Australia's brown tumors this is an
example of regular JC spine and a
patient green luster dystrophy and a
close-up view of the superior slow
erosion on the radial aspect of the
femur sometimes you can see it on the
lateral end of the clavicle desorption
again marrow fibrosis that I showed you
earlier I think I will stop here and
I'll entertain the question over to you
don thank you dr. ralph for bringing
that information to us excellent
presentation before we get started with
our audience questions I just want to
remind attendees how they can submit
questions to you today questions can be
sent via the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window if
you click on the green Q&A button typing
your question in the box that appears
will read it out to dr. Rao and get his
feedback for you I just want to give our
audience just a few minutes to find a
button and ask any questions that they
have but that was certainly an
informative presentation dr. Rao and the
illustrations of what can happen
in this kind of disease process I think
are especially valuable for our
attendees today so we'll keep an eye
here on the QA and see if we have
anything in coming for you and that is
the the green Q&A button is if a lower
left if dr. Rao if there's any other
slides or any other information that you
have while we're waiting for questions
you're certainly welcome to do that okay
we do have a question in our queue
coming up and an attending asks since
vitamin D is important in PTH function
how much direct Sun is required on a
daily basis to maintain adequate vitamin
D levels in the body canal okay that's a
very good question in general the
simplest way is to take 1000 to 2000
units of vitamin B on a daily basis in
cases where the vitamin DS level is very
low and there's urgency in replacing it
particularly if the pth levels are
elevated in concert with low
25-hydroxyvitamin D the one could use
pharmacologic doses like 50,000 units
every week for 8 to 12 weeks but in
general principles 1,000 per day
probably forever should be helpful in
most circumstances great thank you we
have another question coming in does the
784 fragment have any physiological
activity
actually an excellent question although
we do not know the full in human
physiology but 7 284 when injected into
the rats can cause hypocalcemia some
people believe that it may be an
antagonistic action of the 12 84
secreted directly from the parathyroid
gland but it's proof that it actually
exists in that form from the parathyroid
gland is not there so at the present
time we do not know of its physiologic
function but it interferes with the
essay and there's some experimental
evidence to suggest that it may be a
hypocalcemic hormone secreted by pth but
further repetitive test by other
investigators is needed hope that helps
bridge thank you we have another
question at what calcium level should
one consider the involvement of PTH I
assume they are asking about the
hypercalcemia but I alarms it in both
ways as long as the serum calcium is
above the reference range then the PTH
measurement becomes imperative whether
it is normal or elevated then then it is
a diagnostic of hydropower parison in
contrast in the low calcium's range the
PTH level becomes important if it is
very lower and detectable it consistent
with high popara but if it is very high
then it one genetic causes may be a
possibility but within the reference
range ETS becomes less important in most
osteoporosis screening programs the
digital levels are within the reference
range I hope that answers the question
thank you okay we do have another
question from an attendee who asks is
there a single blood test to detect any
abnormalities in parathyroid function
oh that's an interesting question but
I'm not sure I understand the question
as long as the calcium is normal there
is no single blood test so in the usual
clinical practice as long as the serum
calcium is normal there is no reason to
measure the PTH except in the
circumstances where you need to measure
the PTH such as patients with
osteoporosis where do you suspect
calcium deficiency are vitamin D
deficiency I would say if if one has to
do here single test to determine the
calcium and vitamin D balance perhaps
more and more I think about it p th
probably is more profitable more prop
more pragmatic than any other single
test but I don't think we have a single
test unfortunately like we have a fire
function using TSH as a single test but
in the case of calcium metabolism you
must have calcium iron PTH at the same
time to be able to interpret or to you
okay thank you our next question that we
have can calcium and vitamin D
supplements raise the level of thyroid
I'm not sure he meant to ask ty Roy
Donna parathyroid but I'll uh I'll
answer both the first part of his
question the way he has calcium and
vitamin D level supplements do not
increase the thyroid hormone levels
however taking calcium supplements with
thyroid supplementation may impair their
absorption and might alter the test but
does not directly out of the test it
might alter the test because calcium
interface with Alex and absorption on
the other hand if he is asking
parathyroid yes calcium and vitamin D
supplements do change the parathyroid
hormone levels the lower the vitamin D
calcium intake the higher the PTH and
vice versa so in otherwise healthy
individual taking low calcium in low
vitamin D P th ese becomes
useful as a global test to assess
calcium and vitamin D nutritional status
over to you thank you for that as a
following on from that question do
sometimes patients who take thyroid
supplements is it advised that they take
a calcium supplement separate from that
or maybe don't take it with milk is
there a problem with it directly
interfering with thyroid medications yes
in general the answer is yes they should
take the thyroid medications away from
the calcium in addition by the way I
don't also interferes with the thyroid
hormone absorption so that the thyroid
pill must be taken at least an hour
before they take calcium and iron
supplements the practical way would be
to take their calcium and iron
supplements with their meals like
breakfast lunch or dinner whereas
thyroxine supplements should be taken
first thing in the morning only with
water away from food overview great okay
thank you thank you for that answer um I
don't see any more questions in our QA q
I just want to give our audience a
couple of minutes if they want to enter
any more questions for you and I don't
want to leave anybody behind and okay um
I don't see anything else coming in um
dr. route since we oh we do have one
great there we go ah an attendee asks
what's the highest level of dosage for
thyroid supplement um I'm not
expert in that area but I can answer as
an endocrinologist it depends on the
body size the rough rule of thumb is 1.6
micrograms per kilogram body weight so
there's no higher law it depends on
individual patient individual
circumstances for example patients who
had gastric bypass surgery may require
more hormone than others hope that
answers thanks / teal okay great we've
had a couple of audience members asked
about this presentation just to let you
know presentation will be available for
on-demand replay for about six months
after today's live events so that will
be available for audience members who
are asking about information from this
presentation and I don't see any other
questions but I did want to address that
about a couple of people who had asked
about information being available after
today's live presentation I want to put
it back to dr. Rao do you have any final
comments or advice for our attendees on
your topic today no I don't have any
comments other than I hope my
presentation was very helpful I want to
thank the audience for taking the part
away from their schedules to listen to
me and I hope they will find the webinar
to be available in the next six months
to be useful in their clinical practice
and I'm hoping that the newer PT HSA
will be helpful but clinicians to make
the diagnosis little more securely then
we had in the past over to thank you
doral for your time and spending your
time with us today bringing us this
important information I also want to
thank our sponsor dear sorne for making
it possible to bring this presentation
to you as I said today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing here's
December 2016 any attendees today will
be receiving an email from labyrinth
alerting them when this webcast is
available for replay and we would invite
you to forward that email to any of your
colleagues you may have missed today's
live webcast if there was a question you
didn't get to ask or that we didn't get
to today we will definitely follow up
with you via email once again I'd like
to thank dia Soren providing this
webcast and dr. Rao for his time that's
all we have for today we hope to see you
again goodbye